[موسيقى]
البدايه من القدس المحتله حيث اقتحم وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايتامار بن جرير
ومجموعه من المستوطنين باحات المسجد
الاقصى تحت حمايه الشرطه جاء الاقتحام
بالتزامن مع اول جلسه عقدتها حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو الجديده من جبل الزيتون
في القدس تنضموا الينا مراسله الجزيره
نجوان السمري ونجوان اخر التطورات في شان
هذا الاقتحام الذي نفذته اليوم
او تصريحات لمسؤول في مكتب بنيامين
نتنياهو رئيس الوزراء الذي تجاهل هذا
اليوم الحديث عن اقتحام بن كبير المسجد
الاقصى خلال جلسه الحكومه الاولى التي
عقدها لكن ماعز زياد وتوالي الانتقادات
الواسعه محليا ودوليا همم تحديدا من الدول
العربيه حياله هذا الاقتحام ربما الطره
نتنياه الى تسريب هذا البيان من خلال
تصريحات ادلى بها مسؤول في مكتبه لوسائل
الاعلام
الاسرائيليه قال فيها بان نتنياهم ملتزم
بالوضع القانوني الراهن في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك
اي تغيير خلال هذه الحكومه على الوضع
القائم وقال ااه المصدر بان
نتنياهو يقول انه لن يكون كاي رضوخ لما
وصفه باملاءات حركه حماس وانه في السابق
كان هناك زيارات لوزراء سابقين في
الحكومات السابقه
للمسجد الاقصى هو يسميه بطبيعه الحال جبل
الهيكل ولكن التسميه هي المسجد الاقصى
وانه ااه ضمن هذا الوضع الراهن كانت هذه
الزيارات ولذا يضيف نتنياهو بان الادعاءات
التي تقول ان هناك مساس او تغيير في الوضع
الراهن لا اساس لها من الصحه ولكن انا
اريد ان اشدد ايضا عندما قام وزراء سابقون
في الحكومات السابقه وكان ابرازهم
اريل وكان رئيسه الاتحاد القومي وهو
امتداد لاحزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه بزياره
بالاقتحام للمسجد الاقصى في عام 2015 وعام
2018 احدث ذلك همم يعني ادى الى تفجر موقف
وفي اعقاب هذا الاقتحام قرر رئيس الوزراء
في حينه بنيامين نتنياهو الا يقوم اعضاء
في الكنيست او وزراء بزياره المسجد الاقصى
حتى حضر على النواب العرب الا بتنسيق مسبق
مع رئيس الحكومه والاجهزه الامنيه واليوم
زياره بنك فير رغم انها متكرره بالنسبه
لشخصيته ولطال مقام باقتحام المسجد الاقصى
المبارك في السابق لكنها تحمل رمزيه كبيره
ورساله تحدي واستفزاز واضحه لا سيما انه
يفعل ذلك مباشره بعد ان تولى منصب وزاره
الامن القومي وهي وزاره الشرطه التي تؤمن
له هذه الاقتحامات وهذا من الواضح بانه
يحدد سياسات هذا الوزير بخصوص المسجد
الاقصى وكل المخاوف لدى الفلسطينيين
والعرب والمسلمين حيل ما يريد ان يرسخه
بين كبير في المسجد الاقصى لا سيما هو ان
هناك كانت مطالب قبل
من قبل اتباعه للمفوض العام للشرطه بتغيير
الوضع القائم من خلال السماح لهم بزيارات
اطول ساعات اكثر فتح المسجد الاقصى امامهم
ايام الجمعه والسبت والسماح لهم باداء
الصلاه على نيه في كل الاوقات دون حتى
مرافقه من قبل شرطه الاحتلال شكرا جزيلا
لك مراسلاتنا نجوان سمري من جبل الزيتون
في